[Musica]
si mangia con la cultura si mangia
piuttosto bene direi
siamo siamo l'italia siamo il paese
della cultura per eccellenza siamo il
paese che deve riprogrammare in qualche
modo l'atteggiamento nei confronti dei
musei dei teatri
chiamiamola industria culturale
chiamiamo industria culturale le
strutture che devono in qualche modo
riprogrammare rivivere rivedere il prof
la propria relazione con il territorio
con le persone e si inizia a pensare un
museo come un'impresa
intanto pensiamo che un museo di fatto è
una struttura che eticamente deve
pensare alle persone ha una finalità
sociale oltre che culturale
tutte le persone possono accedere al
museo tutte le persone possono essere
accolte da un museo tante persone devono
poter trovare in un museo
tante tante risposte allora esiste
ovviamente una strategia che possa in
qualche modo rendere quasi indipendenti
le strutture culturali dalle pubbliche
amministrazioni
questa è la sfida ovvero in questo
momento non ce la fanno gli stati a
livello internazionale a sostenere i
musei
noi abbiamo quasi 7 mila in italia
piccoli medi e grandi
ebbene sono nuove strategie che partono
dalle nuove funzioni nuove funzioni
legate ovviamente un atteggiamento nuovo
oltre alle funzioni tradizionali
conservazione esposizione promozione ora
il museo e il teatro si atteggiano alla
stregua di un'impresa privata hanno
target di riferimento profilano le
persone cercano di coinvolgere persone e
hanno ovviamente dei degli atteggiamenti
leggermente differenti del precedente
ci sono i successi ovviamente ci sono i
percorsi devono essere in qualche modo
portare avanti e obiettivi chiari
fondamentale sapere cosa vogliamo
proporre al territorio alle persone
sapere come coinvolgere le persone
io mi occupo di marketing non
convenzionale si tratta di marketing
esperienziale emozionale e relazionale
il museo diventa una piattaforma
esperienziale il museo diventa un luogo
di accoglienza
come si può crescere culturalmente ma al
tempo stesso possiamo divertirci
possiamo scambiare e condividere
esperienze possiamo incontrare persone
possiamo realmente vivere una
piattaforma esperienziale perfino
quotidianamente entrando nel mercato del
tempo libero delle persone questo è
importante perché dal momento io riesco
a segmentare il pubblico lo riconosco lo
profilo sono cinque paroline magiche
interessante da questo punto di vista io
devo intercettare pubblici
devo conoscere le devo segmentare vedevo
coinvolgere e le devo fidelizzare sono
meccanismi molto simili a un'impresa
privata ma che con un museo di qualunque
genere
la collezione permanente non è più
sufficiente come attrattiva le mostre
temporanee importantissime non bastano
più
ci vogliono una serie di eventi una
serie di prodotti una serie di percorsi
che possono permettere una struttura
museale di dare risposte creare bisogno
al al desiderio delle persone ascoltarle
e in qualche modo assecondarle fin dove
è possibile ovviamente
ed ecco i servizi i servizi non sono
tanto quanto spazi dedicati ai
frequentatori abituali del museo
i servizi sono vere e proprie strutture
indipendenti che colloquiano con il
museo ma al tempo stesso hanno un appeal
indipendente una veramente forte
attrattivo ed ecco che il book shop in
shop spazi didattici non diventano
servizi secondari o accessori ma sono
veramente i protagonisti di una
struttura riuscito a cambiare perfetto
perché il museo è considerato o deve
essere considerato come un impresa
perché ovviamente a competitor e non
sono gli altri musei non sono altre
strutture espositive o i teatri
il compito del museo sono le strutture
del tempo libero sono i ristoranti sono
i pub sono i campus sportivi sono i
palazzetti dello sport
tutto ciò che è intrattenimento le
persone vanno al museo nel tempo libero
del fine settimana probabilmente nella
loro quotidianità non possono
interrompere una giornata
ebbene il museo deve tenere in
considerazione questi elementi e al
tempo stesso deve raccontare deve
sollecitare deve stimolare e deve in
qualche modo coinvolgere il
coinvolgimento prevede un atteggiamento
più elastico eclettico ma al tempo
stesso un atteggiamento manageriale
signori si parla di governance museale
governance teatrale non dobbiamo
spaventarci
non c'è la casualità non c'è il miracolo
di gestione della cultura
questa è scienza scienza esatta il
manager deve saper gestire una struttura
e gestirla significa essere consapevole
e pianificarla nel tempo con obiettivi a
breve medio lungo termine
esattamente come qualunque impresa avrà
questo punto con obiettivi misurabili e
misurati posso rendermi conto se la
struttura la mia scatola una macchina
può funzionare sempre in una relazione
con il territorio
sempre in relazione con le persone che
vivono anche il territorio ma ovviamente
non posso ignorare il turismo non posso
ignorare strutture analogo
internazionale sono un'impresa e come
tale deve portare a casa risultati è
dice sociali morali culturali e
economici fondamentale e guardate
l'economia non va a intaccare l'etica va
a sostenere un progetto sia fondamentale
prima parlavamo del pil prodotto interno
lordo
io vorrei parlare del pif prodotto
interno di felicità della cultura ai
anche piacere
la cultura è anche divertimento
e un museo dove le persone si divertono
e frequentato non sopporto le persone
che dicono
peccato io ho dodici presenze al mese il
museo non funziona peccato non è
conosciuto il direttore va cambiato la
staticità modificata c'è qualcosa non va
è colpa di chi gestisce non c'è dubbio
quindi un museo
se va male non è un caso ha una pessima
gestione è una pessima strategia
ovviamente i rischi sono grandissimi
esempio il rischio più grande è
rivolgerti solamente agli specialisti
agli addetti a lavori a studiosi che di
non avere ovviamente un percorso
privilegiato ma non il solo
quindi atteggiamento d'isola isolamento
territoriale errore gravissimo grandi
musei che hanno 5 mila persone
all'opening e poi 5 mila persone nei
quattro mesi successivi gravi errori di
comunicazione
ma qual è l'errore più grave non
profilare non posso comunicare in modo
unilaterale
devo sapere esattamente a chi raccontare
qualcosa come raccontarlo quando
raccontarlo e soprattutto coinvolgimento
e partecipazione
non si scherza ho avuto la fortuna di
fare tanta esperienza internazionale di
imparare tantissimo da paesi improbabile
anche asiatici e latinoamericani
ho imparato tantissimo nella gestione
nel coordinamento nel coinvolgimento la
passione dei latinoamericani e la
gestione e feroce business oriented
degli asiatici
allora noi siamo veramente il paese più
più importante si può dire a bassa voce
a livello internazionale che detiene un
peso importante culturale non è il 72
per cento che si che si vocifera è un po
meno ma comunque abbiamo la storia
incredibile bene sfruttiamo questa
storia e gli assicuro che la cultura un
propulsore infinito abbiamo giocato a
lucca con queste sperimentazioni e la
sfida sta andando abbastanza bene ora
luca è piccola come cita il nostro museo
piccolo a 1.600 metri di spazio ma siamo
riusciti ovviamente pian pianino
a raggiungere dei buoni risultati
intanto struttura propulsiva propositiva
abbiamo un ristorante all'interno
dividiamo l'arte moderna al
contemporaneo
diamo spazio agli artisti giovani con
installazioni site specific e siamo
aperti a tutti i pubblici il palazzo
ovviamente storico la parte storica non
impedisce minimamente la contaminazione
attila proattiva e lucida tra il passato
e il presente è interessantissimo le
persone sono preparate sono aiutate
non sono numeri a chi sta in reception
sorride quando entrò le persone offre
informazioni accompagna e cerca
realmente di assecondare le necessità
delle persone
siamo azienda l'azienda deve accogliere
il cliente che va rispettato va
assecondato laddove possibile va aiutato
a comprendere aiutato a vivere
un'esperienza emozionale valutato ad
aprirsi spesso c'è un pregiudizio
ferocissimo da parte delle persone non
entro in un museo dell'arte moderna e
contemporanea perché non ho cultura
non conosco i codici certamente non mi
piacerà
questo per cento più grande è il
problema più grande da affrontare bene
fatti aiutare fatti coinvolgere spazi
espositivi aperti neutrali liberi ogni
persona può comunque fruire a modo
proprio degli spazi da tre a 300 anni
tutte le persone possono accedere un
museo e trovare una risposta è trovare
un pretesto per essere coinvolti e
trovare il modo per divertirsi
uso questa parola in modo costante
divertimento star bene io ritorno in un
museo e sto bene in questo museo si è
anche mio
un klein interessantissimo di musei nord
europei enjoy your museum stai bene nel
tuo museo non è mio il museo
cinquecento affreschi cinquecenteschi
contaminate installazione non è eresia
culturale e contaminazione e anche un po
gioco ma in tempo stesso e riflessione
ogni persona è portata veramente in modo
libero a cercare dei punti di
riferimento interiori esteriori
cerebrali filosofici
tutto è possibile e ognuno ha ragione
perché ognuno trova la propria strada
ormai i codici della tecnologia i codici
4.0 videoarte fotografia video
istallazioni ormai la tecnologia entra
forte nel museo entra forte della
creatività i mercati quindi il museo e
proprio mercato
tra i mercati di riferimento la pubblica
amministrazione
le aziende private e il pubblico
generico a bendetto pubblico generico
deve essere coinvolto in tanti modi in
modo tailor made personalizzato ma anche
le aziende
l'app bonus da solo non basta una
piccola cifra quindi l'azienda arriva a
quella cifra e sente spesso sponsor la
sponsorship è finita
non c'è più nessuno neanche i nostri
amici più cari che possono permettersi
oggi di elargire somme di denaro a fondo
perduto oggi una partnership le tende
sono protagoniste sono partner di un
museo
le aziende non regalano soldi le
investono e le aziende vogliono qualcosa
in cambio e in cambio non hanno solo
immagine ma contatti con pubblici di
riferimento hanno match il museo
seleziona pubblici perché ha profilato
pubblici tra le aziende
noi abbiamo almeno due brand ogni anno
che ci aiutano ma noi aiutiamo loro e
non c'è da vergognarsi non c'è
contaminazione non intacchiamo laura
importante della cultura assolutamente
la valorizziamo e andiamo avanti in
questo modo
raccontiamo storie possiamo coinvolgere
tante persone attraverso lo story
telling una mostra importante può essere
trasformata in un opera teatrale anno
inviamo a contaminare andiamo a
coinvolgere è un grande un grandissimo
dispendio di energie emotive fisiche ma
un modo per chiamare al museo persone
che altrimenti non entrerebbero mai chi
non viene al museo certamente accettano
le tracce
questo è chiaro quindi invitare a cena
persone raccontare una storia cercare
una un collegamento con le opere cercare
un riferimento con l'artista cercare un
riferimento interiore attraverso un
percorso eno gastronomico che ammicca
fortissimo all'essenza della mostra di
un certo momento e poi dibattiti
confronti conferenze che poi si anche
anche concerti musica il moto può essere
anche non convenzionale alcuni spazi
possono essere contaminati da altre
espressioni artistiche
ormai non c'è più un linguaggio unico
ormai tutte le cose sono legate ci
arriviamo a cercare risposte
laddove ci sono domande le domande le
fanno ovviamente i pubblici di
riferimento e sono tutti potenziali
pubblici di riferimento e poi andiamo a
far comprendere la genesi dell'arte la
genesi della creazione facciamo vivere
il momento alle persone questo è altra
cosa importante ovvero condividere il
momento creativo significa non
comprendere esattamente e
scientificamente il significato di
un'opera ma condividerla viverla
parteciparla ovviamente il vivaio i
bambini una risorsa pazzesca incredibile
il bambino critico d'arte naturale non
ha non ha filtri trasparente nella
pregiudizio il bambino si getta a pieno
cuore nell'arte moderna e contemporanea
e la vive magari avessimo
l'atteggiamento come bambini ovviamente
investiamo tantissimo come museo sui
bambini
anche quando bambini hanno 10 anni
cosa vuol dire un bambino che a 0 anni
zero cosa significa 0 anni
se non è ancora nato e quindi non
facciamo dei lavoratori anche per le
madri in dolce attesa
attraverso ovviamente dei pedagogisti
specializzate in questo e sembra e qui
però dovrà presentare le mamme che ci
sia una qualche risposta con una
sollecitazione acustica mono tema però
qui qui si va in una dimensione dove io
non posso approfondirla i numeri nove
anni di vita grandi eventi piccoli
eventi tantissimi eventi collaterali
tantissime proposte interdisciplinari
il tutto per 350.000 visitatori
diecimila bambini il sogno diventa
realtà
se cuore mente coraggio intraprendenza
identità vengono avuti insieme se ci
crediamo senza dubbio ce la possiamo
fare
ringrazio
[Musica]